diese fackel ist auf jeden fall sehr
sehr plastisch das muss man schon sagen
man sieht hier ganz ganz stark die 3d
konturen so kann man die fackel auch
sehr gut erkennen richtig gut
[Musik]
hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen
letzte test und zwar spielen wir heute
mal das spiel meint hess tan und ja
minecraft und platz testete so eine
fusion das habe ich entwickelt das haben
keine ahnung wer das gemacht hat das hat
chor die will opas unter anderem per
turbo laura legg pilz adam lassen wir
das wir haben hier irgendwas ich weiß
auch gar nicht wie das genau
funktioniert ich hab mir schon der welt
gemacht
seht ihr hier den tollen namen das ist
noch im kreativ modus und es gab den
schaden sogar eingestellt gehabt glaube
ich und so sieht das ganze aus dass sie
quasi genau so aus wie minecraft ihr
können hier ganz normal einstellung
sound lautstärke einstellen sonst können
wir ihnen gern glaube ich gar nix
einstellen wir sehen hier die
standardtastatur bewegung via sd es ganz
klar laufen leertaste springen klettern
also wir können hier werde ganz normal
blöcke hoch springen wir können zwei
blöcke können wir nicht hoch springen
wie kann ein blog hochspringen kriechen
und herunterklettern was kriechen um
schach so umstellt ja umschalt ist halt
ganz normal auch mal kräftig daran herum
scheint das ist für mich shift aber gut
ihr kennt es so so ganz normal
er wird er 15 mich übrigens nicht uns so
bereits vielfach mäßig von anderen
sachen sondern wir sehen ja halt die
prozesse die gerade da sind und wir
sehen halt auch unsere lädt das oben
links unter meinte es seht ihr zum
beispiel unsere koordinaten das
komplette welt aufbausystem also der
komplette der irgendwie ich mache mal
mit der steuerung weiter hieß inventar
nicht so wie minecraft also wir können
ja auch kräften et cetera wir können
jetzt sei alles möglich reinlegen komme
ich gleich noch zu
wir können auch raps moment hier die
sache wenn ihr das hier zum beispiel
habe dann ist diese oberste zeile das
was ihr gerade im winter habt und nicht
das unterste die blöcke sind dort auch
mehr oder weniger gleich schreibt dich
erst mal nachmachen okay es ist danach
mache
aber es ist halt an sich jetzt auch noch
mal ich finde es gibt schon ein bisschen
so wie alten minecraft alpha
verhältnisse vor wenn ich etwas richtig
simple spielen wollt ohne irgendwie
großartige redstone konfigurations
sachen oder so könnt ihr echt einfach
dieses spiel spielen das ist einfach
minecraft alpha ja das ist einfach
minecraft einfach es ist es ist
eigentlich einfach so es heißt mein test
aber wir machen mal ganz kurz mit den
steuern wie gesagt links habe ich schon
gemacht ganz normal abbauen
rechts platzieren ganz hier nochmal
blöcke hinsetzen gibt es dann noch nicht
zum coolen sound ich meine der glocke
der sound ist das bei jedem loch gleich
also dass minecraft hat schon
mittlerweile bessere viele mehr vorteile
sage ich mal
allerdings ist es halt so dass ich finde
dass minecraft halt nicht in die falsche
richtung geht auf jeden fall eine sehr
komplexe richtung was er auf der einen
seite auch gut ist allerdings möchte ich
auch manchmal solche leichten spiele
spielen was ja auch schon seht es dass
wir ganz einfach hier so blätter abbauen
können und sonst gibt's auch zur
steuerung zu sagen mausrad item
auswählen tsz und coo seiten droppen
also ist alles so wie minecraft das mit
dem i das ist bei minecraft hat
mittlerweile offen weil die weiß ich gar
nicht glaubt nicht dass aufträge
lediglich weiß es nicht ich habe keine
ahnung ich glaube das ist mittlerweile
so vorgegeben wir wollen uns jetzt
eigentlich mal so ein bisschen hier so
ich weiß nicht letzte test ist ja
eigentlich mal so ich bereite mich vor
bei diesem spiel gibt es nichts
vorzubereiten außerhalb so zu sagen dass
das komplette spiel so aufgebaut ist wie
minecraft ich habe hier noch mit der
erweiterte steuerung gefunden und zwar
ist zum beispiel ein steak ausgeben also
das kann man wirklich im inventar machen
ha erst die entfernung wartet so da da
sieht man full range dass ich mir jetzt
ich mache das einfach so eigentlich mag
ich dass er lieber wenn da so nebel ist
das sieht so ein bisschen klose aus aber
wir lassen euch mal so dass feiert ihr
jetzt eigentlich geglaubt die steuerung
schon sehr schwammig das muss man schon
sagen es gibt halt man kann nicht
sprinten oder so man kann ganz normal
laufen
wie halt minecraft also wollen wir da
hinlaufen was ist das was sind das dazu
ich wollte schon optimal mäßig suchen
wir können es ja erst mal hier so ein
bisschen dahin muss immer auf ihr
drücken so hier kommen wir nämlich ganz
normal hier wurden place machen wie
gesagt die sachen heißen auch gleich und
alles mögliche so hey das ist aber gar
nicht möglich fällt mir grad auf
annehmen man muss einfach nur so rein
und die rezepte sind doch nicht alle
gleich
ist scheiße ich dachte die rezepte wenn
nicht alle gleich hier sind sie auch
nicht gleich ist das hin crafting table
nee das ist eine truhe und die mache ich
mit einem kräftigen table sagt nicht ich
muss das so hinnehmen wo sie nicht also
wie ich bin crafting table mache weiß
ich gerade nicht aber eigentlich ist das
hier auch schon crafting table fällt mir
gerade zu auf während ich das hier so
sage eigentlich so das muss ich auch
noch beachten dass das da oben die zeile
ist und nicht das da unten das so also
das ist ja auch witzig das ist mir
gerade ist aufgefallen dass er drei
kästchen sind findest du von minecraft
gewöhnt so erstmal so ihr wisst bescheid
gewusst los also eventuell wenn ihr
wollt mache ich den zweiten part raus
aber ich denke wollte das nicht ich
mache jetzt einfach ein letztes was 20
minuten geht schauen wir mal ob da noch
irgendwelche mops kommen weil eigentlich
sollten mops kommen ich bin ja
eigentlich auch auf der richtigen stufe
also wir können halt noch mit haar zum
beispiel nooteboom schnallten umschalten
ist es halt enabled und disabled club
sollte die eigentlich kennen sonst gut
er ist einfach mal speed umschalten
können wir auch noch mit j so sind wir
zum beispiel fest also verändert sich
einfach nichts auffällig und fliegen
kann machen was ich ach ich bin ja auch
in dem komischen mode hier gerade ach
stimmt so ich bin ja auch rad im
normalen modus
ich bin ja gar nicht kreativ nutzen
kreativ modus könnt ihr damit york
fliegen und soll das ist dann warum ich
jetzt eigentlich schon runter ich wollte
wieder oben endlich ein geiles haus
drauf egal warum uns das hier unten und
dann bin ich die da hinten auch schon
kohle
wir bauen uns einfach mal wo wir uns im
haus einbauen also hier ist wasser
animation natürlich wählen die wasser
animation diese richtig richtig gut hier
ist doch ein schöner platz mensch so ich
mache mir erstmal auch stücke wie
erstmal hier eine schöne spitzhacke spox
am start war nicht immer ein bisschen
runter versucht warum glaube ich nicht
überhaupt darunter ich sehe doch da
vorne sind steinchen glaube ich mir da
mal ein paar steinchen weggeschnappt
hatte ich auch gut
ich trinke oder hinten sich auch schon
äpfel am horizont
so gibt mir erstmal wie kommen
eigentlich keine steinchen raus doch da
kommt steinchen raus aber deutschen die
das ist mir schon bei den blättern
aufgefallen wurden die steine kloppen
nicht so richtig und das wasser fließt
auch gar nicht also das wasser hat noch
nicht diese engine das vlies ist weil
bei minecraft ganz ganz damals auch so
dass mein gott das wasser nicht rhein
geflossen ist sondern wasser war halt da
wie ein block durch den man durch kann
mehr oder weniger in dem man glaube ich
kann man hier trinken im wasser ich
probier's mal man kann man nicht
ertrinken
aber da unten sich zum beispiel kohl und
man kann auch unter wasser genauso gut
sehen wir über wasser ist auch witzig
man kann auch genauso schnell ab und
realisiere ich gerade
also wie gesagt ich mach das ist dann so
ein let's play hier gerade was ich
obwohl das möchte ich mal ganz kurz
rausfinden ob das möglich ist dass ich
einfach ich kann mich ja normal darin
bewegen weil das ja ganz normale blöcke
sind kann ich mir noch mal dann laufend
schillig also das ist halt mehr so einen
let's play an testfahrt so gucke ich mir
das mal an du bist die anderen und das
beschreibt was los so jetzt hier hoch
hier
ich komme nie mehr raus ist cool doch
komme ich so mein ziel ist jetzt erst
mal wie ein haus zu bauen dann möchte es
auch beenden also kann man spielen wenn
man so minecraft mäßig mal wieder auf in
alpha zurück möchte da weil das ist ja
mittlerweile echt sehr komisch da zurück
zur dayton und als ich glaube
mittlerweile ist es sogar relativ easy
peasy mit dem dings mit neuen lounge
aber hey guck mal hier fließt wasser
das können wir gleich mal mehr angucken
machen jetzt erstmal hier die grund und
resilienz sondern hier noch ein
schwätzchen nein ich möchte nicht
wegschmeißen
sodann bauen uns das hier war ganz
normal auf so da mache ich hier noch ein
paar fältchen weil ich sehe schon es
wird schon langsam dunkel
wieso bekommt nicht viel verkehr kommen
zwei fackeln raus also es sind
innovative neuerungen ihrem start aber
sonst ich finde das spiel es ist einfach
minecraft und schlecht das muss man so
sagen da möchte ich mich auch nicht
lumpen
ich kriege ja auch nichts dafür dass ich
das hier vorstellt ich habe es halt nur
deckt und dachte mir sondern alle die
der indiso lust dann hätten zeige ich
dir doch mal also könnt euch ja ne
anguckt nach hinten ich weiß noch gar
nicht ob schon gibt
ich schaue mich um jetzt noch die äpfel
die da hinten rum backen dann bauen uns
erst mal ein kleines häuschen ist nicht
was wir bei uns jetzt erstmal ein
kleines häuschen weil ich habe schon ein
bisschen angst denn jetzt irgendwie
plötzlich doch so ein scheiß pratzen
kommt dann sind wir ganz schön am arsch
und die gibt es auch keine helligkeit
bisher deswegen wenn wir doppelt am
arsch ist der bescheid bis meine hallo
also gibt ja keine helligkeit
einstellungen die fackeln sind auch mehr
als scheiße ich gesagt die verkennen bin
total gut meine ich kenne mich hier
fühle ich mich noch ein bisschen holz
oft es geht auf jeden fall gar nicht
schneller
doch es gibt ein bisschen schneller aber
nicht viel wollen wir unseren kleinen
unterstützt ihren versuchen immer zu die
nacht zu verbringen
ich weiß auch gar nicht ob hier
überhaupt schon monster sind in
minecraft ganz am anfang ich vergleiche
es halt immer mit minecraft weil es halt
wirklich minecraft ist mehr oder weniger
allerdings find ich halte diese
beleuchtung echten hammer geil weil
damals konnte man nicht so wenn eine
stadt dadurch so richtig hervorheben
mittlerweile ist einfach alles okay
diese fackel ist auf jeden fall sehr
sehr plastisch das muss man schon sagen
man sieht hier ganz ganz stark die 3d
konturen
so kann man die fackel auch sehr sehr
gut erkennen richtig gut
na gut da packe ich jetzt schönen erde
hin so wie ich das natürlich gehört wenn
wir uns das ganze natürlich ein bisschen
auch die tür menschen und die küste
ordnung da kommt etwas für die kiste hin
just danke dass wir das so schön
erklärst so da kommen jetzt mal schön
die koppel stars ryan und die wii zieht
das heißt wii zeitalter die brauche ich
erstmal anschluss sogar kommt unsere
schöne tür hin so kommen wir schönes
hier ging es darum gestoppt und hier
kommt schön er da rein gekleidet aber
nicht mehr so gut haben wir hier noch
einmal weg bekommst dann beispielsweise
dass ein dettling dahin und bekommst
dahin dann haben wir unsere schöne unser
schönes haus so hier stellen und
sipplingen vielleicht wächst ja
irgendwann mal ein baum
wer weiß wer weiß
so dich brauche ich dich brauche ich und
ich brauche ich das heißt ich kräfte mir
jetzt mal eine hohe dass die who
und jetzt mache ich das mal etwas das
man einfach ihr im wasser kann ich das
nicht mehr machen ich muss sagen ich
kann nicht mit rechtsklick soft heiliger
samen wachsen
ich stelle die pflanze fackel da mal ein
bisschen mehreren zu den beiden hier
damit der hier ein bisschen licht hat
und damit er da unten ich stelle ich
meine da unten hin
dann habt ihr beide licht und dann könnt
ihr bei eventuell sogar wachsen das wäre
cool
so wie jedes mal ein bisschen so monster
angucken ich sehe mal gar nichts
natürlich habe ich nicht noch ein
bisschen habe ich nicht noch habe ich
eine habe ich noch an masse aber ich hab
keinen kern dings mehr muss ein bisschen
bäume fällen klar
das soll jetzt nicht dann werde ich mein
großes haus habe ich wollte es noch ein
dach und dann ich kann ja mal versuchen
wie soll ich mit dem bett machen ich
glaube die nächte ging ja bis zum 1.4
ging es ja auch nicht musste man ja
gedacht hat dass wir eine spinne daran
dass äpfel
ihr müsst immer bedenken conny ist
contis profi ist kein news krone müsste
auch übrigens jetzt immer in die
kommentare schreiben ich zeige euch wenn
nicht dann ziehe ich euch eure youtube
erlaubnis das ist auf jeden fall so dass
darf mittlerweile haben wir ganz
vergessen zu machen
oh mensch leute dachten wir immer noch
nicht warum sagt er dennoch nichts die
sitzt da und er sagt einfach nichts mehr
das ist ich traurig soll ja sagen wir
doch hier mehr oder weniger so wie man
ein bisschen hier rumlaufen bei nacht ob
wir noch etwas finden menschen da kommen
wir doch läuft man hier einfach dran
ich glaube dass ich schlecht aus äpfel
sie mir den äpfeln kann ich den jetzt
auch essen oder oder ist einfach nur da
ich drücke immer immer so natürlich kann
die nur hinsetzen essen kann ich dir
nicht so obwohl mit mit links oder
zuckerrohr gibt's auch und blaue blume
blaue blume mein gott ein unterschied
zum ein gehabt da gib mir mal deinen
glauben den äpfeln vielleicht mit
linksklick mit links gegessen
innovative neuerungen auf jeden fall
also wenn ihr das und schillig also ihr
seht schon die die engineer dies auch am
start ist natürlich ganz klar können wir
auf jeden fall ein bisschen bücher
ausmachen und die bücher die können wir
dann nachher das ist jetzt nicht
unrealistisch und jetzt gehe ich hier
schon wieder unterwegs um sobald hatte
was mich mal interessieren würde wenn
ich da an block abbauen ich bin
automatisch ihr euch kriegen automatisch
egal wie weit weg ist der fällt nicht
jedem fällt einfach direktem ein
inventar rheine meldet ihr an minecraft
auch so ihr bauten blog update 1000
blöcke weg und er fällt einfach direkt
zu euch so mein ziel wird es sein jetzt
ein bisschen diesen tempel hier noch
auszuleuchten
für außen rum und dann war es ist auch
eigentlich schon soll er sich jetzt des
todes lang gehen
das soll er einfach nur ehrlich erst mal
einen groben überblick darüber geben
über dieses spiel
mir gefällt es wenn ich so eine
nostalgische phase habe und dann wenn
man sage so moment minecraft war damals
so cool natürlich das geht auch einfach
so ins wasser platzieren dass wir
könnten quasi einfach einen sehr kaputt
machen indem ihr einfach ganz viele
fackeln ihnen die rein platzieren
einfach in ihn rein kann ich das hier
machen kann ich auch machen cool sind
dann kommst du noch hier hin und da habe
ich jetzt keine mehr aber dass ich doch
schon mal cool aus oder
also das ist echt so cool so die
beleuchtung so von damals so mega cool
ich weiß nicht gefällt mir
also das war mein test mein test meint
es zu meinen test kann ich irgendwie
screenshots machen also da kann ich
nicht ich weiß nicht wie bei f2 chatten
also das ist können wir sind schreiben
hai singleplayer hat mit mir selber
hi
er spürt bei der ja gut dass mein haus
klar bei dem haus oder mond geht gerade
unter könnten auch abwarten aber ich
weiß noch nicht was ich machen soll weil
wir eröffnen sich keine möglichkeiten in
dieser dunkelheit gut freunde wenn es
euch gefallen hat und wenn ihr mal
wieder letztes spieler haben wollt dann
schreib mir letzten testspielen die
kommentare und eventuell auch eure
meinung zu diesem spiel
das sehen wir also minecraft alpha es
ist kostenlos von daher beschwert euch
nicht es ist einfach kostenlos man
sollte sich über kostenlose spiele
beschweren etwas kosten würde wäre eine
frechheit ist weil es ist einfach
minecraft sind schlecht aber wenn man so
wie der minecraft alpha spielen möchte
ist es ganz natürlich
multicar geht übrigens auch glaube ich
der chat geht einfach nicht weg doch ich
kann hinten machen multiplayer geht
glaube ich auch also im hauptmenü war
hier mehr spieler jetzt ich nehme jetzt
mal was kann ich denn machen verbinden
geht das jetzt da bauen wir nicht welche
adressen wie der anderen hat
wahrscheinlich über hagi dann wieder
sonst ja wie gesagt hat euch gefallen
habe ich meine daumen hoch freuen ihr
könnt mir die kommentare schreiben was
ihr davon haltet und mit welcher version
ihre minecraft angefangen habt es wäre
auch mal ganz witzig zu erfahren und
dann will ich sagen tschüss und bis zum
nächsten mal
[Musik]